The Joe Rogan Experience the thing that
you find over time is that people
understand you like they'll watch your
podcast with Andrew and they've seen you
guys for hundreds of hours yes they know
you right so like when you're talking if
you say something if you misstep or you
know if you say something that doesn't
turn out to be that they know what
you're trying to do they know you're not
a vicious person you're just trying to
be funny and you're never going to be
perfect uh this is the biggest
opportunity in my life I'm gonna walk
out here being like I wish I said that
one thing differently of course did you
take any sh like do you have this
defensive Apu this is a [ __ ]
hilarious bit thank you so much man
thank you it's so dead huh it's like why
is that offensive why is that guy
offensive but does anybody give you a
hard time about that I'm getting some
comments yeah and what I want to
delineate I think is the word like
differential delineate thank you I'm not
as smart as I should be but what I want
to differentiate is the difference
between your hurt feelings and being
oppressed your hurt feelings are valid
and if kids kids made fun of me for it
that's valid that hurt I can go talk to
it therapist but you're not [ __ ]
oppressed and that's what I thought
canceling a pool was it was we think
we're oppressed and we're not at all
with that [ __ ] well there's a lot of
things going on right like first of all
there's a white guy doing the voice yeah
what's that dude's name Henry Azaria the
[ __ ] yeah that's my guy bruh he was
on uh what else was he on oh he's done
accident he's in everything he's been a
bunch of them he does a hilarious French
accent and Along Came Polly that's so
over the top and so ridiculous but it's
so funny he's a guy that just does
Accents well you're allowed to do French
people though yeah because it's like
they don't have extra melanin they don't
have extra melanin and I see how it's
worse but I also what that this guy the
voice yeah yeah dude that's so [ __ ]
funny are you for scuba yeah yes dude
it's so funny Lubin what is that movie
in Along Came Polly it's a it's a movie
most people hate but I love it's one of
those romantic comedies Jennifer Aniston
Ben Stiller but he wasn't wasn't he in a
sitcom he's in oh yeah for sure probably
he's in everything I just thought I have
I understand the context with which The
Simpsons was created it was a show that
came out in the late 80s I didn't know
any Indian actors much less voice over
actors to do that voice so he did it and
then he brought it to life and I looked
at the Simpsons and I said this is the
most three-dimensional supporting
character in that entire show everybody
else is ecstatic Chief Wiggum is static
MO is completely static Barney's a drunk
loser all the time a poo is like
three-dimensional and he evolves more
than every character on that show
including the Simpsons he gets married
he loses a business gains a business has
kids becomes a father so like I love
that story that's a beautiful story he's
the American dream on that show have
they completely removed him from the
show he's gone from the show and I think
it's [ __ ] because dude a poo if it was
voiced by by a brown person a pooh is so
many of our parents and I don't mean
that and I mean that in the most
respectful way like I used to always
hear um back in the Heyday people would
say The Simpsons represents every level
of society that's why the politician is
a sleaze bag and the billionaire is a
corrupt [ __ ] in a pool I really thought
whether they mentor not represented the
American dream he came to this country
in search of a better life he worked
hard he was mostly honorable and he
built a [ __ ] life and that is our
parents and we should all be so proud of
our parents and it sucks that a white
guy was doing the voice but at the time
I don't think they had an option he's
doing 12 voices they just threw him one
extra right they didn't have a budget
and then he made it something so I would
say some of the jokes were a little
hacky you can evolve those but you don't
get rid of the guy completely it was an
over correction